welcome everyone uh this is natural
language understanding
it is a weird and wonderful and maybe
worrying moment to be doing natural
language understanding
my goal for today is just to kind of
immerse Us in this moment and think
about how we got here and what it's like
to be doing research now and I think
that'll set us up well to think about
what we're going to do in the course and
how that's going to set you up to
participate in this moment in AI uh in
many ways in whichever ways you choose
and it's an especially impactful moment
to be doing that and this is a project
oriented course and I feel like we can
get you all to the point where you are
doing meaningful things that contribute
to this ongoing moment in ways that are
going to be exciting and impactful that
is the fundamental goal of the course
let's now think about the current moment
this is always a moment of reflection
for me I started teaching this course in
which I guess is ages ago now it feels
recent in my lived experience but it
does feel like ages ago in terms of the
content in 2012 on the first day I had a
slide that looked like this I said it
was an exciting time to be doing natural
language understanding research I noted
that there was a Resurgence of interest
in the area after a long period of
people mainly focused on syntax and
things like that
but there was a widespread perception
that nlu was you was on was poised for a
breakthrough and to have huge impact
that was relating to business things and
that there was a white hot job market
for Stanford grads a lot of this
language is coming from the fact that we
were in this moment when Siri had just
launched Watson had just won on Jeopardy
and we had all of these in-home devices
and all the tech Giants kind of
competing on what was emerging as the
field of natural language understanding
let's fast forward to 2022 I did feel
like I should update that in 2022 by
saying this is the most exciting moment
ever as opposed to just being an
exciting time but I emphasize the same
things right we were on in this feeling
that we had experienced a Resurgence of
interest in the area although now it was
hyper intensified same thing with
industry the industry interest at this
point makes the stuff from 2012 look
like small potatoes
systems were getting very impressive but
and I maintained this here they show
their weaknesses very quickly and the
core things about nlu remain far from
solve so the big breakthroughs lie in
the future I will say that even since
2022 it has felt like there has been an
acceleration and some problems that we
used to focus on feel kind of like
they're less pressing I won't say solve
but they feel like we've made a lot of
progress on them as a result of models
getting better but all that means for me
is that there are more exciting things
in the future that we can tackle even
more ambitious things and you'll see
that I've tried to overhaul the course
to be ever more ambitious about the kind
of problems that we might take on
but we do kind of live in a golden age
for all of this stuff and even in 2022
I'm not sure what I would have predicted
to say nothing of 2012 that we would
have these incredible models like Dolly
2 which can take you from text into
these incredible images language models
which will more or less be the star of
the quarter for us but also models that
can take you from natural language to
code and of course we are all seeing
right now as we speak that the entire
industry related to web search is being
reshaped around nlu Technologies so
whereas this felt like a kind of Niche
area of NLP when we started this course
in 2012 now it feels like the entire
field of NLP certainly in in some
aspects all of AI is focused on these
questions of natural language
understanding which is exciting for us
one more moment of reflection here you
know in this course throughout the years
we have used simple examples to kind of
highlight the weaknesses of current
models and so a classic one for us was
simply this question which U.S states
border no U.S states the idea here is
that it's a simple question but it can
be hard for our language Technologies
because of that negation the no there
in 1980 there was a famous system called
chat 80. it was a symbolic system
representing the first major phase of
research in NLP you can see the fragment
of the system here and chat 80 was an
incredible system in that it could
answer questions like which country
bordering the Mediterranean borders a
country that is bordered by a country
whose population exceeds the population
of India I've given you the answer here
turkey at least according to 1980s
geography but if you asked chat Adie a
simple question like which U.S states
border no U.S states it would just say I
don't understand it was an incredibly
expressive system but rigid it could do
some things very deeply as you see from
the first question but things that fell
outside of its capacity it would just
fall down flat
that was the 1980s let's fast forward
2009 around the time this course
launched wolf from alpha hit the scene
and this was meant to be a kind of
revolutionary language technology the
website is still up and to my amazement
it still gives the following Behavior if
you search for which U.S states border
no U.S states it kind of just gives you
a list of the U.S states revealing I
would say that it has no capacity to
understand the question posed
that was 2009 so we've gone from 1980 to
2009. okay let's go to 2020. this is the
first of the open AI models Ada which
U.S states border no U.S states the
answer is no and then it sort of starts
to babble the U.S border is not a state
border it did that for a very long time
but about Babbage this is still 2020.
the U.S states border no U.S states what
is the name of the U.S state and then it
really went off the deep end from there
again for a very long time that was
Babbage if you had seen this output well
at least for me it might have shaken my
faith that this was a viable approach
right
but the team persisted I guess 2021 this
is the Curie model which U.S state
supporter no U.S states it had a problem
that it started listing things but it
did say Alaska Hawaii and Puerto Rico
which is an interestingly more
impressive answer than the first answer
right it still has some problem
understanding what it means to respond
but it's looking like we're seeing some
signal
Da Vinci instruct beta this is 2022.
it's important I think that this is the
first of the models that have instruct
in the name we'll talk about that in a
minute which U.S states border no U.S
states Alaska and Hawaii we've from 2020
to 2022 we have seen this astounding
Leap Forward making everything before
then sort of pale in comparison and then
finally text DaVinci won you know one of
the new Best in Class models at least
until two months ago which U.S states
border no U.S states Alaska and Hawaii
are the only U.S states that border no
other U.S states a very impressive
answer indeed and if you just think
about the little history I've given a
kind of microcosm of what is happening
in the field
a lot of time without much progress with
some hype attached and now in the last
few years this kind of Rapid progress
forward
and you know that's just one example but
these examples multiply and we can
quantify this here's another impressive
case I asked the DaVinci 2 model in
which year was Stanford University
founded when did it enroll its first
students who is its current president
and what is its mascot a complicated
question indeed and it gave a fluent and
factually correct answer on all counts
this is The DaVinci 3 model which was
best in class until a few weeks ago and
it gave exactly the same answer very
impressive
now in this course and for for you'll
see at the website one of the readings
we've suggested for the start of the
course is this classic paper by Hector
Levesque called on our best behavior and
the thrust of this article essentially
channeling Terry Winograd and Terry
winograd's schema the idea is that we
should come up with examples that will
test whether models deeply understand
and in particular get past the kind of
simple memorization of statistics and
other things about the data they're
trained on and really probe to see
whether they understand what the world
is like and Levesque and winograd's
technique for doing this is to pose very
unlikely questions where humans have
very natural answers like one of the
ones Levesque poses is could a crocodile
run the Steeplechase
maybe it's a question you've never
thought about before but you probably
have a pretty consistent answer across
this group could a crocodile run the
Steeplechase here I asked another one of
levesque's questions are professional
baseball players allowed to glue small
Wings onto their caps you could think
about that for a second The DaVinci 2
model said there is no rule against it
but it is not common and that seemed
like a very good answer to me at the
time when the da Vinci 3 engine came out
though this started to worry me no
professional baseball players are not
allowed to glue small Wings onto their
caps Major League Baseball has strict
rules about the appearance of players
uniforms and caps
and any modifications to the Caps are
not allowed
okay I thought I was feeling good about
this but now I don't even myself know
what the answer is our professional
baseball players allowed to glue small
Wings onto their caps we have two
confident answers that are contradictory
across two models that are very closely
related starting to worry us a little
bit I hope but still it's impressive
what's that
you could check yes I have a few cases
and this is an interesting experiment
for us to run for sure let me show you
the responses I got a bit later
the point though I guess if you've seen
the movie Blade Runner this is starting
to feel like to figure out whether an
agent we were interacting with was human
or AI we would need to get very
sophisticated sophisticated interview
techniques indeed the touring test long
forgotten here now we're into the mode
of trying to figure out uh exactly what
kind of Agents we're interacting with by
having to be extremely clever about the
kinds of things that we do with them
now that's kind of anecdotal evidence
but I think that the picture of progress
is also supported by what's happening in
the field let me start this story with
our benchmarks and the headline here is
that our benchmarks the tasks the data
sets we use to probe our models are
saturating faster than ever before and
I'll articulate what I mean by saturate
so we have a little framework along the
x-axis I have time stretching back into
like the 1990s and along the y-axis I
have a normalized measure of distance
from what we call Human Performance
that's the red line set at zero each one
of these benchmarks has in its own
particular way set a so-called estimate
of human performance I think we should
be cynical about that but nonetheless
it'll this will be a kind of marker of
progress for us
First Data set mnist this is like digit
recognition famous task in AI it was
launched in the 1990s and it took about
20 years for us to see a system that
surpassed human performance in this very
loose sense
the switchboard Corpus this is going
from speech to text it's a very similar
story launched in the 90s and it took
about 20 years for us to see a
superhuman system
imagenet this was launched I believe in
2009 and it took less than 10 years for
us to see a system that surpassed that
red line
and now progress is going to pick up
really fast Squad 1.1 the Stanford
question answering data set was launched
in 2016 and it took about three years
for it to be saturated in this sense
Squad 2.2.0 was the team's attempt to
pose an even harder problem one where
they were unanswerable questions but it
took even less time for systems to get
past that red line
then we get the glue Benchmark this is a
famous Benchmark in natural language
understanding a multi-task benchmark
when this was launched a lot of us
thought that glue would be too difficult
for present-day systems it looked like
this might be a challenge that would
stand for a very long time but it took
like less than a year for systems to
pass Human Performance the response was
super glue but it was saturated if
anything even more quickly
now we can be as cynical as we want
about this notion of human performance
and I think we should dwell on whether
or not it's fair to call it that but
even setting that aside this looks like
undeniably a story of progress the
systems that we had in 2012 would not
even have been able to enter the glue
Benchmark to say nothing of achieving
scores like this so something meaningful
has happened now you might think by the
standards of AI these data sets are kind
of old here's a post from Jason way
where he evaluated our latest and
greatest large language models on a
bunch of mostly new tasks that were
actually designed to stress test this
new class of very large language models
and Jason's observation is that we see
emergent abilities across more than a
hundred tasks for these models
especially for our largest models the
point though is that we again thought
these tasks would stand for a very long
time and what we're seeing instead is
that one by one systems are certainly
getting traction and in some cases
performing at the standard we had set
for humans again an incredible story of
progress there
so I hope that is energizing maybe a
little intimidating but I hope
fundamentally energizing for you all uh
the next question that I want to ask for
you is just what is going on what is
driving all of this sudden progress
let's get a feel for that and that'll
kind of serve as the foundation for the
course itself
before I do that though are there
questions or comments
things I could resolve or things I left
out about the current moment
write it on board it did very well
we should we should reflect though maybe
as a group about what it means to do
very well my my question for you when
you say it did well what is the Major
League Baseball rule about players
gluing things onto their caps
you found the actual rule no
Bard found that rule and gave me that
number okay
yes that is going to be the question for
us I can get which is right for
hallucination well I'm going to show you
the open AI models will offer me links
but the links go nowhere
[Music]
what you're pointing out I think is an
increasing societal problem these models
are offering us what looks like evidence
but a lot of the evidence is just
fabricated and this is worse than
offering no evidence at all what I
really need is someone who knows Major
League Baseball to tell me what is the
rule about players and their caps I want
it from an expert human not an expert
language model
be careful how you Google though I guess
that's the lesson of 2023
all right what's going on let's start to
make some progress on this again first a
little bit of historical context I've
got a timeline going back to the 1960s
along the x-axis this is more or less
the start of the field itself and in
that early era essentially all of the
approaches were based in symbolic
algorithms like the chat 81 that I
showed you in fact you know that was
kind of pioneered here at Stanford by
people who were pioneering the very
field of AI and that Paradigm of
essentially programming these systems
lasted well into the 1980s
in the 90s early 2000s we get the
statistical Revolution throughout
artificial intelligence and then in turn
in natural language processing and the
big change there is that instead of
programming systems with all these rules
we're going to design machine learning
systems that are going to try to learn
from data under the hood there was still
a lot of programming involved because we
would write a lot of feature functions
that were little programs that would
help us detect things about data and we
would hope that our machine Learning
Systems could learn from the output of
those feature functions but in the end
this was the rise of the fully
data-driven learning systems and we just
hope that some process of optimization
leads us to new capabilities
the next big phase of this was the Deep
learning Revolution this happened
starting around
2009-2010 again Stanford was at the at
the Forefront of this to be sure it felt
like a big change at the time but in
retrospect this is kind of not so
different from this mode here it's just
that we now replace that simple model
with really big models really deep
models that have a tremendous capacity
to learn things from data we started
also to see a shift even further away
from those feature functions from
writing little programs and more toward
a more mode where we would just hope
that the data and the optimization
process could do all the work for us
then the next thing big thing that
happened which I could could take us I
suppose until about 2018 would be this
mode where we have a lot of pre-trained
parameters these are pictures of maybe
big language models or computer vision
models or something and when we build
systems we build on those pre-trained
components and Stitch them together with
these tasks specific parameters and we
hope that when they're all combined and
we do some learning on some tasks
specific data we have something that's
benefiting from all these pre-trained
components
and then the mode that we seem to be in
now that I want us to reflect critically
on is this mode where we're going to
replace everything with maybe one
ginormous language model of some kind
and hope that that thing that enormous
black box will do all the work for us I
think we should think critically about
whether that's really the path forward
but it certainly feels like the
Zeitgeist to be sure
question yeah
um if you think it's worth it could you
go back to the last slide um and maybe
explain a little bit a more grounded
example of what that all means I
couldn't quite follow let's do that
later the point for now though is really
this shift from here where we're mostly
learning from scratch from our for our
task here we've got things like Bert in
the mix we've got you know pre-trained
components models that we hope begin in
a state that gives us a leg up on the
problem we're trying to solve that's the
big thing that happened and you get this
emphasis on people releasing model
parameters you know in this earlier
phase like here there was no talk of
releasing model parameters because
mostly the models people trained were
just good for the tasks that they had
set
as we move into this era and then
certainly this one these things are
meant to be like general purpose
language capabilities or maybe general
purpose computer vision capabilities
that we stitch together into a system
that can do more than any previous
system could do
right so then we have this big thing
here
so that's the feeling now behind all of
this certainly beginning in this Final
Phase here is the Transformer
architecture
just may take the temperature of the
room how many people have encountered
the Transformer before
right yeah it's sort of unavoidable if
you're doing this research here's a
diagram of it but I'm not going to go
through this diagram now because
starting on Wednesday we are going to
have an entire lecture essentially
devoted to unpacking this thing and
understanding it all I can say for you
now is that I expect you to go on the
following Journey which all of us go on
how on Earth does the Transformer work
it looks very very complicated I I hope
can get you to the point where you feel
oh this is actually pretty simple
components that have come been combined
in a pretty straightforward way that's
your second step on the journey the one
the true Enlightenment comes from wait a
second why does this work at all
and then you're with the entire field
trying to understand why these simple
things were brought together in this way
have proved so powerful
the other major thing that happened
which is kind of latent going all the
way back to the start of link of AI
especially as it relates to Linguistics
is this notion of self-supervision of
distributional learning because this is
going to unlock the door to us just
learning from the world in the most
General sense
in self-supervision your model's only
goal is to learn from co-occurrence
patterns in the sequences that it's
trained on the sequences can be language
but they could be language plus sensor
readings computer code maybe even images
that you embed in this space just
symbols and the model's only goal is to
learn from the distributional patterns
that they contain
or for many of these models to assign
high probability to the attested
sequences in whatever data that you pour
in
for this kind of learning we don't need
to do any labeling all we need to do is
have lots and lots of symbol streams
and then when we generate from these
models we're sampling from them and
that's what we all think of when we
think of prompting and getting a
response back but the underlying
mechanism is at least in part this
notion of self-supervision and I'll
emphasize again because I think this is
really important for why these models
are so powerful the symbols do not need
to be just language they can include
lots of other things that might help a
model piece together a full picture of
the world we live in and also the
connections between language and those
pieces of the world just from this
distributional learning
the result of this proving so powerful
is the Advent of large-scale
pre-training because now we're not held
back anymore by the need for labeled
data all we need is lots of data in
unstructured format this really begins
in the era of static word
representations like word to vac and
glove
and in fact those teams and I would say
especially the glove team they were
really Visionary in the sense that they
not only released a paper
and code but pre-trained parameters this
was really brand new for the field this
idea that you would Empower people with
model artifacts and people started using
them as the inputs to recur recurrent
neural networks and other things and you
started to see pre-training as an
important component to doing really well
at hard things
there were some predecessors that I'll
talk about next time but the really big
moment for contextual representations is
the Elmo model this is the paper deep
contextualized word representations I
can remember being at the North American
ACL meeting in New Orleans in 2018 at
the best paper session they had not
announced which of the best papers was
going to win the outstanding paper award
but we all knew it was going to be the
Elmo paper because the gains that they
had reported from fine-tuning their Elmo
parameters on hard tasks for the field
were just mind-blowing the sort of thing
that you really only see once in a kind
of generation of This research or so we
thought because the next year
Bert came out same thing I think same
best paper award thing the paper already
had had huge impact by the time it was
even published and they too released
their model parameters Elmo is not
Transformer based Bert is the first of
the sequence of things that's based in
the Transformer and again lifting all
boats even above where Elmo had brought
us
then we get GPT this is the first GPT
paper and then fast forward a little bit
we get gpt3 and that was pre-training at
a scale that was previously kind of
unimaginable because this we're now
we're talking about you know for the
Bert model 100 million parameters and
for gpt3 well north of 100 billion
different order of magnitude and what we
started to see is emergent capabilities
that model size thing is important again
this is a sort of feeling of progress
and maybe also despair I think I can
lift your spirits a little bit but we
should think about model size so I have
years along the x-axis again
and I have model size going from 100
million to 1 trillion here on a
logarithmic scale
so 2018 GPT that's like 100 million Bert
I think it's 300 million for the large
one okay gbt2 even larger Megatron 8.3
billion I remember when this came out I
probably laughed maybe I thought it was
a joke I certainly thought it was some
kind of typo because I couldn't imagine
that it was actually billion like with a
B there
um but now that's you know we take that
for granted Megatron 11 billion this is
20 21 or so then we get gpt3 reportedly
at 175 billion parameters and then we
get this thing where it seems like we're
doing typos again Megatron Turing nlg
was like 500 and then Palm is 540
billion parameters and I guess there are
rumors that we have gone upward all the
way to a trillion right there's an
undeniable Trend here I think there is
something to this trend
um but we should reflect on it a little
bit one thing I want to say is there's a
noteworthy pattern of very few entities
have participated in this very large in
this race for very large models we've
got like Google Nvidia meta and open AI
right and that was actually a real cause
for concern I remember being at a
workshop between Stanford and open AI
where the number one source of
consternation was really that only open
AI at that point had trained these
really large models and after that
predictably these other large tech
companies kind of caught up
but it was still for a while looking
like a story of real centralization of
power
that might still be happening but I
think there's a reason to be optimistic
so here at Stanford the helm Group which
is part of the center for research on
Foundation models LED this incredibly
ambitious project of evaluating lots of
language models and one thing that
emerges from that is that we have a more
healthy ecosystem now so we have these
like loose collectives big science and a
Luther are both kind of fully open
source groups of researchers we've got
well one academic institution
represented this could be a little bit
embarrassing for Stanford maybe we'll
correct that and then maybe the more
important thing is that we have lots of
startups represented so these are well
funded but relatively small outfits that
are producing outstanding language
models and so the result I think we're
going to see much more of this and then
we'll worry less about centralization of
power there's plenty of other things to
worry about so we shouldn't get sanguine
about this but this particular point I
think is being alleviated by current
trends and there's another aspect of
this too which is I have the scary ryzen
model size but what is happening right
now as we speak in a very quick way is
we're seeing a push towards smaller
models and in particular we're seeing
that models that are in the range of
like 10 billion parameters can be highly
performant right so we have the flan
models we have llama and then here at
Stanford they release the alpaca thing
and then uh data bricks released Hello
Dolly model these are all models that
are like eight to ten billion parameters
which I know this sounds funny because I
laughed a few years ago when the
Megatron model had 8.3 billion and now
what I'm saying to you is that this is
relatively small but so it goes and the
point is that a 10 billion parameter
model is one that could be run on
regular old commercial Hardware whereas
these monsters up here really you have
lots of pressures towards centralization
of power there because almost no one can
work with them but anyone essentially
can work with alpaca and it won't be
long before we've got the ability to
kind of work with it on small devices
and things like that and that too is
really going to open the door to lots of
innovation I think that will bring some
good and I think it will bring some bad
but it is certainly a meaningful change
from this scary Trend that we were
seeing until
four months ago
as a result of these models being so
powerful people started to realize that
you can get a lot of mileage out of them
simply by prompting them when you prompt
one of these very large models you put
it in a temporary state by inputting
some text and then you generate a sample
from the model using some technique and
you see what comes out right so if you
type into one of these models better
late than
it's going to probably spit out never
if you put in every day I eat breakfast
lunch and it will probably say dinner
and you might have an intuition that the
reasons the causes for that are kind of
different the first one is a sort of
idiom so that it could just learn from
co-occurrence patterns and text
transparently for the second one we kind
of interpret it as humans as reflecting
something about routines
but you should remind yourself
that the mechanism is the same as in the
first case this was just a bunch of
co-occurrence patterns a lot of people
describe their routines in text and the
model picked up on that and carry that
thought forward as you think about
things like the president of the US is
when it fills that in with Biden or
whoever
it might look like it is offering us
factual knowledge and maybe in some
sense it is but it's the same mechanism
as for those first two examples it is
just learning from the fact that a lot
of people have expressed a lot of texts
that look like the president of the US
is Joe Biden and it is repeating that
back to us
and so definitely if you ask a model
something like the key to happiness is
you should remember that this is just
the aggregate of a lot of data that it
was trained on it has no particular
wisdom to offer you necessarily beyond
what was encoded latently in that giant
sea of mostly unaudited unstructured
text
Yeah question yes
yes I guess you know it'd be kind of
hard to get something like this but if
we had like a corpus of just like you
know all the like language is right but
literally all of the facts were wrong
like we just imagined like a very
factually Ingrid course like like I I
guess I'm getting at like
how do we inject like truth into like
these horses
uh it's a question that bears repeating
how do we inject truth
it's a question you all could think
about what is truth of course but also
um what would that mean and how would we
achieve it and even if we did back off
to something like how would we ensure
self-consistency for a model or you know
at the level of a world view or a set of
facts even those questions which seem
easier to pose are incredibly difficult
questions in the current moment where
our only mechanisms are basically that
self-supervision thing that I described
and then a little bit of what all about
what I'll talk about next but none of
the structure that we used to have where
we would have a database of knowledge
and things like that that is posing
problems
the prompting thing we take this a step
forward right so the gpt3 paper remember
that's that 175 billion parameter
monster the eye-opening thing about that
is what we now call in context learning
which was just the notion that for these
very large very capable models you could
input a bunch of text like here's a
passage
and maybe an example of the kind of
behavior that you wanted and then your
actual question and the model would do a
pretty good job at answering the
question
what you're doing here is with your
context passage and your demonstration
pushing the model to be extractive to
find an answer to its question in the
context passage and then the observation
of this paper is that they do a pretty
good job at following that same behavior
for the actual Target question at the
bottom here remember this is all just
prompting putting the model in a
temporary State and seeing what comes
out you don't change the model you just
prompt it
this in 2012 if you had asked me whether
this was a viable path forward for a
class project I want to prompt an RNN or
something I would have advised you as
best I could to choose some other topic
because I never would have guessed that
this would work so the mind-blowing
thing about this paper and everything
that's followed is that we might be
nearing the point where we can design
entire AI systems on the basis of this
simple in context learning mechanism
transformatively different from anything
that we saw before
in fact let me just emphasize this a
little bit it is worth dwelling on how
strange this is
for those of you who have been in the
field a little while
just contrast what I described in
context learning with the standard mode
of supervision
let's imagine for a case here that we
want to train a model to detect nervous
anticipation and I have picked this
because this is a very particular human
emotion and in the old mode we would
need an entire dedicated model to this
right we would collect a little data set
of positive and negative instances of
nervous anticipation and we would train
a supervised classifier on feature
representations of these examples over
here learning from this binary
distinction
we would need custom data and a custom
model for this particular task in all
likelihood
in this new mode few shot in context
learning we essentially just prompt the
model hay model here's an example of
nervous anticipation my palm started to
sweat as the lotto numbers were read off
hey model here's an example without
nervous anticipation and so forth and it
learns from all those symbols that you
put in in their co-occurrences something
about nervous anticipation
on the left for this model here I've
written out nervous anticipation but
remember that has no special status I've
structured the model around the binary
distinction the one and the zero and
everything about the model is geared
toward my learning goal on the right
nervous anticipation is just more of the
symbols that I've put into the model
and the eye-opening thing again about
the gpt3 paper and what's followed is
that models can learn be put in a
temporary State and do well at tasks
like this
now
I talked about self-supervision before
and I think that is a major component to
the success of these models but it is
increasingly clear that it is not the
only thing that is Driving Learning in
the best models in these in this class
the other thing that we should think
about is what's called reinforcement
learning with human feedback
this is a diagram from the chat GPT blog
post there are a lot of details here but
really two of them are important for us
for right now the first is that in a
phase of training these models
people are given inputs and asked
themselves to produce good outputs for
those inputs
so you might be asked to do a little
Python program and you yourself as an
annotator might write that Python
program for example so that's highly
skilled work that depends on a lot of
human intelligence and those examples
those pairs are part of how the model is
trained and that is so important because
that takes us Way Beyond just learning
from co-occurrence patterns of symbols
and text it is now back to a very
familiar story from all of AI which is
that it's not magic what is happening is
that a lot of human intelligence is is
driving the behavior of these systems
and that happens again at step two here
so now the model produces different
outputs and humans come in and rank
those outputs again expressing direct
human preferences that take us well
beyond self-supervision so we should
remember we had that brief moment where
it looked like it was all unstructured
unlabeled data and that was important to
unlocking these capacities but now we
are back at a very labor-intensive human
capacity here driving what looked like
the really important behaviors for these
models
final step which I think actually
intimately relates to that instruct
tuning that I just described that's a
kind of way of summarizing this
reinforcement learning with human
feedback and this is what's called
step-by-step or Chain of Thought
reasoning now we're thinking about the
prompts that we use for these models
so suppose we asked ourselves a question
like can models reason about negation to
give an example does the model know that
if the customer doesn't have any auto
loan sorry doesn't have any loans then
the customer doesn't have any auto loans
it's a simple example it's the sort of
reasoning that you might have to do if
you're thinking about a car contract or
something like that whether a rule has
been followed and it just involves
negation our old friend from the start
of the lecture
now in the old school prompting style
all the way back in 2021 we would kind
of naively just input is it true that if
the customer doesn't have any loans then
the customer doesn't have any auto loans
into one of these models and we would
see what came back
and here it says no this is not
necessarily true a customer can have
auto loans without having any other
loans which is the reverse of the
question that I asked again kind of
showing it doesn't deeply understand
what we've put in here it just kind of
does an act that looks like it did
and that's worrisome but we're learning
how to communicate with these very alien
creatures now we do what's called
step-by-step prompting this is The
Cutting Edge thing you would just tell
the model that it was in some kind of
logical or common sense reasoning exam
That Matters to the model
then you could give some instructions
and then you could give an example in
your prompt of the kind of thing it was
going to see
and then finally you could prompt it
with your premise and then your question
and the model would spit out something
that looked really good here I won't
bother going through the details but
with that kind of prompt the model now
not only answers and reasons correctly
but also offers a really nice
explanation of its own reasoning
the capacity was there it was latent and
we didn't see it in the simple prompting
mode but the more sophisticated
prompting mode elicited it
and I think this is in large part the
result of the fact that this model was
instruct tuned and so people actually
taught it about how that markup is
supposed to work and how it's supposed
to think about prompts like this so the
combination of all that human
intelligence and the capacity of the
model led to this really interesting and
much better Behavior
that is a glimpse of the foundations of
all of this I would say of course we're
going to unpack all of that stuff as we
go through the quarter but I hope you're
getting a sense for it are there
questions I can answer about it things I
could Circle back on yes the human brain
has about 100 billion neurons is my
understanding uh and I'm not sure how
many parameters
or something
are we approaching a point where these
machines can start emulating the human
brain or is there something to the
language in Spain or you know instincts
of all kinds that maybe take into the
human rights
oh it's nothing but big questions today
right so so the question is kind of like
what is the relationship between the
models we're talking about and the human
brain and you you raise that in terms of
the size and I guess the upshot of your
description was that these models remain
smaller than the human brain yeah I
think that's reasonable
um It's Tricky though on the one hand
they obviously have superhuman
capabilities
um on the other hand they fall down in
ways that humans don't it's very
interesting to ask why that difference
exists
um and maybe that would tell us
something about the limitations of
learning from scratch versus being
initialized by Evolution the way all of
us were
I don't know but I would say that
underlying your whole line of
questioning is the question can we use
these models to eliminate questions of
Neuroscience and cognitive science and I
think we should be careful but that the
answer is absolutely yes and in fact the
increased ability of these models to
learn from data has been really
Illuminating about certain kind of
recalcitrant questions from cognitive
science in particular you have to be
careful because they're so different
from us these models on the other hand I
think they are helping us understand how
to differentiate different theories of
cognition and ultimately I think they
will help us understand cognition itself
yeah
yeah and I would of course welcome
projects that were focused on those
cognitive questions in here this is a
wonderful space in which to explore this
kind of more speculative angle
connecting AI to the cognitive Sciences
other questions comments yes in the back
I'm curious to understand whether I mean
harshly following up on the brain thing
just to use a metaphor of our brain not
being just one huge lump of neurons but
being separated into different areas and
then also thinking about the previous
phase that you talked about about
breaking up the models and potentially
having a model in the front that decides
which domain or question falls into and
then having different
soft models and I'm wondering whether
that's arising whether I want to touch
on an architecture like that
um because it just seems natural to me
because prompting a huge model is just
very expensive computationally
it feels like combining big models and
logic trees could be a cool approach I
love it yeah like one quick summary of
what you said would relate directly to
your question the modularity of mind is
an important old question about human
cognition to what extent are our
abilities modularized in the mind brain
uh
with these current models which have a
capacity to do lots of different things
if they have the right pre-training in
the right structure we could ask does
modularity emerge naturally or do they
learn non-modular Solutions both of
those seem like they could be indirect
evidence for how people work again we
have to be careful because these models
are so different from us but as a kind
of existence proof for example that
modularity was emergent from otherwise
unstructured learning that would be
certainly eye-opening right I have no
idea yeah I don't know whether the
results for that their results
just kind of a follow-up
and on that
and all these big models are how could
we interact with the model of such a way
that helps us learn if there is modulars
because we literally can only attract
so how do we go about studying that
right so the question is you know the
the closed off nature of a lot of these
models has been a problem we can access
the open AI models but only through an
API we don't get to look at their
internal representations and that has
been a blocker but I mentioned the rise
of these 10 billion parameter models as
being performant and interesting and
those are models that with the right
Hardware you can dissect a little bit
and I think that's just going to get
better and better and so we'll be able
to you know peer inside them in ways
that we haven't been able to until
recently yeah
and in fact like we're going to talk a
lot about explainability that's a major
unit of this course and I think it's an
increasingly important area of the whole
field that we have techniques for
understanding these models so that we
know how they're going to behave when we
deploy them and it would be wonderfully
exciting if you all wanted to try to
scale the methods we talk about to a
model that was as big as 8 or 10 billion
parameters ambitious just to do that but
then maybe a meaningful step forward
yeah
um I have a question back to like this
baseball cap comp that we were
discussing
was it like there is a little bit of
ambiguity for like human interpretation
like for example in the honor code in
the fundamental standard like it's
intentionally ambiguous so that it's
context dependent
um and so like the idea that there's
like this inherent underlying value
system that like affords whatever the
rules that are written out are and so
that's like the primary form of
evaluation and so I guess like how does
that play into then how these language
models are understanding like is there
some form of encoded or understanding
understood deeper value system that's
encoded into them
you could certainly ask I mean the
essence of your question is could we
with analysis techniques say uh find out
that a model had a particular belief
system that was guiding Its Behavior I
think we can ask that question now it
sounds fantastically difficult but maybe
piecemeal we could get make some
progress on it for sure yeah I want to
return to the MLB one though because
well as you'll see and as I think we
already saw these models purport to
offer evidence from a rule book
and that's where I feel stuck
the answer and some other stuff in the
class discussion wonderful thank you
yes can we just hook up these models to
a large database information
web oh well kind of Yes actually this is
the sort of solution that I want to
advocate for I'm going to do this in a
minute yeah
here let's uh so we'll do this overview
I want to give you a feel for how the
course will work and then uh dive into
some of our major themes so high level
overview we've got these topics
contextual representations Transformers
and stuff multi-domain sentiment
analysis that will be the topic of the
first homework and it's going to build
on the first unit there retrieval
augmented in context learning this is
where we might hook up to a database and
get some guarantees about how these
models will behave
compositional generalization in case you
were worried that all the tasks were
solved I'm going to confront you with a
task a seemingly simple task about
semantic interpretation that you will
well I think it will not be solved I
mean those could be famous last words
because who knows what you all are
capable of but it's a very hard task
that we will pose
we'll talk about benchmarking and
adversarial training and testing
increasingly important topics as we move
into this mode where everyone is
interacting with these large language
models and feeling impressed by their
behavior we need to take a step back and
rigorously assess whether they actually
are behaving in good ways or whether
we're just biased toward remembering the
good things and forgetting the bad ones
we'll do model introspection that's the
explainability stuff that I mentioned
and finally methods and metrics and as
you can see for the like five six and
seven that's going to be in the phase of
the course where you're you're focused
on Final projects and I'm hoping that
that gives you tools to write really
rich final papers that have great
analysis in them and really excellent
assessments
and then for the work that you'll do
we're going to have three assignments
and each one of the assignments is
paired with what we call a bake off
which is an informal competition around
data and modeling essentially the
homework problems ask you to set up some
baseline systems and get a feel for a
problem and then you write your own
original system and you enter that into
the bake off and we have a Leaderboard
on grade scope and the team is going to
look at all your submissions and give
out some prizes for top performing
systems but also systems that are really
creative or interesting or ambitious or
something like that and that has always
been a lot of fun and also really
Illuminating because it's like
crowdsourcing a whole lot of different
approaches to a problem and then as a
group we can reflect on what worked and
what didn't and look at the really
ambitious things that you all try so
that's my favorite part we have three
offline quizzes and this is just as a
way to make sure you have incentives to
really immerse yourself in the course
material
and those are done on canvas there's
actually a fourth quiz which I'll talk a
little bit about probably next time that
is just making sure you understand the
course policies that's quiz zero you can
take it as many times as you want but
the idea is that that you will have some
incentive to learn about policies like
due dates and so forth
and then the real action is in the final
project and that will have a lit review
phase an experiment protocol and a final
paper those three components you'll
probably do those in teams and
throughout all of that work you'll be
mentored by someone from the teaching
team and as I said before we have this
incredibly expert teaching team lots of
varied expertise a lot of experience in
the field and so we hope to align you
with the person the with someone who's
really aligned with your project goals
and then I think you can go really
really far
forward to because I don't stand for
kids get obsessed about this stuff
on the final project is this more of an
academic paper or a rather about
building working code and
showing of state of the art great
question for the first one the bake offs
yes it is easy to get obsessed with your
Bake Off entry I would say that if you
get obsessed and you do really well just
make that into your final project all
three of them all three of them are
really important problems they are not
idle work I mean one of them is on
retrieval augmented in context learning
which is one of my core research focuses
right now so is compositional
generalization if you do something
really interesting for a bake off make
it your final paper and then go on to
publish it for the second part of your
question I would say that the core goal
is to get you to produce something that
could be a research contribution in the
field and we have lots of success
stories I've got Links at the website to
people who have gone on to publish their
final paper as an NLP paper
I I'm careful the way I say that they
didn't literally publish the final paper
because in 10 weeks almost no one can
produce a publishable paper it's just
not enough time but you could form the
basis for then working a little bit more
or a lot more and then getting a really
outstanding publication out of it and I
would say that that's the default goal
the nature of the contribution though is
highly varied we have one requirement
which is that the final paper have some
quantitative evaluation in it but there
are a lot of ways to satisfy that
requirement and then you could be
serving many different questions in the
field
for some expansive notion of the field
as well
background materials so I should say
that officially we are presupposing
cs224n or cs224s as prerequisites for
the course and what that means is that
I'm going to skip a lot of the
fundamentals that we have covered in
past years
if you need a refresher check out the
background page of the course site it
covers fundamentals of scientific
computing
static Vector representations like word
to VEC and glove and supervised learning
and I'm hoping that that's enough of a
refresher if you look at that material
and find that it too is kind of Beyond
where you're at right now then contact
us on the teaching team and we can think
about how to manage that but officially
this is a course that presupposes cs224n
then the core goals this kind of relates
to that previous question hands-on
experience with a wide range of problems
mentorship from the teaching team to
guide you through projects and
assignments and then really the central
goal here is to make you the best that
is most insightful most responsible most
flexible nlu researcher and practitioner
that you can be for whatever you decide
to do next and we're assuming that you
have lots of diverse goals that somehow
connect with nlu
all right let's do some course themes
unless there are questions
I have a whole final section of this
slideshow that's about the course
materials and requirements and stuff
might save that for next time and you
can check it out at the website and
you'll be forced to engage with it for
quiz zero
um I thought instead I would dive back
into the content part of this unless
there are questions or comments
all right first course theme Transformer
based pre-training
so starting with the Transformer we want
to talk about Core Concepts and goals
give you a sense for what these models
are like why they work what they're
supposed to do all of that stuff we'll
talk about a bunch of different
architectures there are dozens and
dozens of them but I hope that I have
picked enough of them with the right
selection of them to give you a feel for
how people are thinking about these
models and the kind of Innovations they
brought in that have led to real
meaningful advancement just at the level
of architectures we'll also talk about
positional encoding which I think maybe
a lot of us have been surprised to see
just how important that is as a
differentiator for different approaches
in this space
we'll talk about distillation
taking really large models and making
them smaller it's an important goal for
lots of reasons and an exciting area of
research and then as I mentioned it's
going to do a little lecture for us on
diffusion objectives for these models
and then it's going to talk about
practical pre-training and fine-tuning
I'm going to enlist the entire teaching
team to do guest lectures and these are
the two that I've lined up so far
and that will kind of culminate or be
aligned with this first homework and
Bake Off which has a multi-domain
sentiment I'm going to give you a bunch
of different sentiment data sets and
you're going to have to design one
system that can kind of succeed on all
of them and then for the bake off we
have an unlabeled data set for you we
have the labels but you won't and that
has data that's like what you developed
on and then some mystery examples that
you will not really be able to
anticipate and we're going to see how
well you do at handling all of these
different domains with one system
and this is by way of kind of again a
refresher On Core Concepts and
supervised learning and really getting
you to think about Transformers although
we're not going to constrain the kind of
solution that you offer for your
original system
our second major theme will be retrieval
augmented in context learning a topic
that I would not even have dreamed of
five years ago and seem kind of
infeasible three years ago and that we
first did two years one year ago oh
goodness I think this is only the second
time but I had to redo it entirely
because things have happened changed so
much
um here's the idea we have two
characters so far in our kind of
emerging narrative for nlu on the one
hand we have this approach that I'm
going to call llms for everything large
language models for everything
you input some kind of question here
I've chosen a very complicated question
which MVP of a game read Flaherty
umpired was elected to the Baseball Hall
of Fame and hats off to you if you know
that the answer is Sandy Koufax
the llms for everything approach is that
you just type that question in and the
model gives you an answer
and hopefully you're happy with the
answer
the other character that I'm going to
introduce here is what I'm going to call
retrieval augmented so I have the same
question at the top here except now this
is going to proceed differently the
first thing that we will do is take some
large language model and encode that
query
into some numerical representation
that's sort of familiar the new piece is
that we're going to also have a
knowledge store which you could think of
as an old-fashioned web Index right just
a knowledge store of documents with the
modern twist that now all of the
documents are also represented by large
language models but fundamentally this
is an index of the sort that drives all
web search right now
we can score documents with respect to
queries on the basis of these numerical
representations and if we want to we can
reproduce the classic search experience
here I've got a ranked list of documents
that came back from my query just like
when you do Google
as of the last time I Googled
but in this mode we can continue right
we could have another language model
slurp up those retrieved documents and
synthesize them into an answer and so
here at the bottom I've got it's kind of
small but it's the same answer over here
although notably this answer is now
decorated with links that would allow
you the user to track back to what
documents actually
provided that evidence whereas on the
left
who knows where that information came
from and that's kind of what we were
already grappling with
this is an important societal need
because this is taking over web search
what are our goals for this kind of
model here so first we want synthesis
fluency right we want to be able to take
information from multiple documents and
synthesize it down into a single answer
and I think both of them approaches that
I just showed you are going to do really
well on that we also need these models
to be efficient
to be updatable because the world is
changing all the time
we need it to track Providence and maybe
invoke something like factuality but
certainly Providence we need to know
where the information came from and we
need some Safety and Security we need to
know that the model won't produce
private information and we might need to
restrict access to parts of the model's
knowledge to different groups like
different customers or different people
with different Privileges and so forth
that's what we're going to need if we're
really going to deploy these models out
into the world
as I said I think both of the approaches
that I sketch do well on the synthesis
part because they both use a language
model and those are really good they all
have the Gift of Gab so to speak
what about efficiency right on the llm
for any for everything approach we had
this undeniable rise in model size and I
pointed out models like alpaca that are
smaller
but I strongly suspect that if we are
going to continue to ask these models to
be both a knowledge store and a language
capability we're going to be dealing
with these really large models
the hope of the retrieval augmented
approach is that we could get by with
the smaller models and the reason we
could do that is that we're going to
factor out the knowledge store into that
index and the language capability which
is going to be the language model the
only thing we're going to be asking the
language model is to be good at that
kind of in-context learning it doesn't
need to also store a full model of the
world and I think that means that these
models could be smaller so overall a big
gain in efficiency if we go retrieval
augmented people will make progress but
I think it's going to be tense
what about updateability again this is a
problem that people are working on very
concertedly for the llms for everything
approach but these models persist in
giving outdated answers to questions
and one pattern you see is that there's
a lot of progress where you could like
edit a model so that it gives the
correct answer to who is the president
of the US but then you ask it about
something related to the family of the
president and you re it reveals that it
has outdated information stored in its
parameters and that's because all of
this information is interconnected and
we don't at the present moment know how
to reliably do that kind of systematic
editing
okay on the retrieval augmented approach
we just re-index our data right if the
world changes we assume that the
knowledge store changed like somebody
updated a Wikipedia page so we represent
all the documents again or at least just
the ones that changed and now we have a
lot of guarantees that as that
propagates forward into the retrieved
results which are consumed by the
language model it will reflect the
changes we made to the underlying
database in exactly the same way that a
web search index is updated now
right one forward pass of the large
language model compared to maybe
training from scratch over here on new
data to get an absolute guarantee that
the change will propagate
what about Providence okay we have seen
this already this problem here llms for
everything I asked
um
gpt3 The DaVinci 3 Model my question are
professional baseball players allowed to
glue small Wings onto their caps but I
kind of cut it off but at the top there
I said provide me some links to the
evidence
and it dutifully provided the links but
none of the links are real if you copy
them out and follow them they all go to
404 pages
and I think that this is worse than
providing no Links at all because I'm
attuned as a human in the current moment
to see links and think they're probably
evidence and I don't follow all the
links uh and here you might look and say
oh yeah I see it found the relevant MLB
pages and that's it right over here the
kind of the point of this is that we are
first doing a search phase where we're
actually linked back to documents and
then we just need to solve the
interesting non-trivial question of how
to link those documents into the
synthesized answer but all of the
information we need is right there on
the screen for us and so this feels like
a relatively tractable problem compared
to what we were faced with on the left I
will say I've been in just amazed at the
rollout especially of of the Bing search
engine which now incorporates open AI
models at some level because it is clear
that it is doing web search right
because it's got information that comes
from documents that only appeared on the
web days before your query
but what it's doing with that
information seems completely chaotic to
me
so that it's kind of just getting mushed
in with whatever else the model is doing
and you get this unpredictable
combination of things that are grounded
in documents and things that are
completely fabricated and again I
maintain this is worse than just giving
an answer with no evidence attached to
it
why these companies are not simply doing
the retrieval augmented thing but I'm
sure they are going to wise up and maybe
your research could help them wise up a
little bit about this
finally Safety and Security this is
relatively straightforward on the llms
for everything approach we have a
pressing problem
privacy challenges we know that those
models can memorize long strings in
their training data and that could
include some very particular information
about one of us and that should be
worrying us
we have no known way with a language
model to compartmentalize llm
capabilities and say like you can see
this kind of result and you cannot and
similarly we have no known way to
restrict access to part of an llm's
capabilities
they just produce Things based on their
prompts and you could try to have some
prompt tuning that would tell them for
this kind of person or setting do this
and not that but nobody could guarantee
that that would succeed whereas
for the retrieval augmented approach
again we're thinking about accessing
information from an index and access
restrictions on an index is an old
Problem by now again I don't want to say
solved but something that a lot of
people have tackled for decades now and
so we can offer something like
guarantees just from the fact that we
have a separated knowledge store
again my smiley face you can see where
my feelings are for the llms for
everything approach you know people are
working on these problems and it's very
exciting and if you want a challenge
take you know take up one of these
challenges here but over here on the
retrieval augmented side I think we have
lots of reasons to think it's not that
they're completely solved it's just that
we can see the path to solving them and
this feels very urgent to me because of
how suddenly this kind of technology is
being deployed in a very user-facing way
for one of the core things we do in
society which is web search
so it's it's an urgent thing that we get
good at this
final things I want to say about this so
until recently the way you would do even
the retrieval augmented thing would be
that you would have your index and then
you might train a custom purpose model
to do the question answering part and it
could extract things from the text that
you produced or maybe even generate some
new things from the text that you
produced
and that's kind of the mode that I
mentioned before where you'd have like
some language models maybe a few of them
and you'd have an index and you would
stitch them together into a question
answering system that you would probably
train on question answering data and you
would hope that this whole big monster
may be fine-tuned on squad or natural
questions or one of those data sets gave
you a general purpose question answering
capability
that's the present but I think it might
actually be the recent past and in fact
the way that you all will probably work
when we do this unit and certainly for
the homework is that we will just have
Frozen components this starts from the
observation that the retriever model is
really just a model that takes in text
and produces text with scores
and a language model is also a device
for taking in text and producing text
with scores
these are when these are frozen
components you can think of them as just
black box devices that do this input
output thing and then you get into the
Intriguing mode of asking well what if
we had them just talk to each other
and that is what you will do for the
homework and Bake Off You will have
Frozen Retriever and a Frozen large
language model and you will get them to
work together
to solve a very difficult open domain
question answering problem
and that's kind of pushing on us into a
new mode for even thinking about how we
design AI systems where it's not so much
about fine-tuning it's much more about
getting them to communicate with each
other effectively to design a system
from Frozen components
again unanticipated at least by me as of
a few years ago and now an exciting New
Direction
so just to wrap out I think what I'll do
since we're near the end of the of class
here I'll just finish up this one unit
and then we'll use some of our time next
time to introduce a few other of these
course themes and that'll set us up well
for diving into Transformers final piece
here just to inspire you few shot open
QA is kind of the task that you will
tackle for homework too and here's how
you could think about this imagine that
the question has come in what is the
course to take
the most standard thing we could do is
just prompt the language model with that
question what what is the course to take
down here and see what answer it gave
back right but the retrieval augmented
Insight is that we might also retrieve
some kind of passage from a knowledge
store here I have a very short passage
the course to take is natural language
understanding and that could be done
with a retrieval mechanism
but why stop there it might help the
model as we saw going back to the gpt3
paper to have some examples of the kind
of behavior that I'm hoping to get from
the model and so here I have retrieved
from some data set question answer pairs
that will kind of give it a sense for
what I want it to do in the end
but again why stop there we could also
pick questions that were based very
closely on the question that we posed
that would be like K nearest neighbors
approach where we use our retrieval
mechanism to find similar questions to
the one that we care about
I could also add in some context
passages and I could do that by
retrieval so now we've used the
retrieval model twice potentially wants
to get good demonstrations and wants to
provide context for each one of them
but I could also use my retrieval
mechanism with the questions and answers
from the demonstration to get even
richer connections between my
demonstrations and the passages I could
even use a language model to rewrite
aspects of those demonstrations to put
them in a format that might help me with
the final question that I want to pose
so now I have an interwoven use of the
retrieval mechanism and the large
language model to build up this prompt
right
down at the retrieval thing I could do
the same thing and then when you think
about the model generation again we
could just take the top response from
the model but we can do very
sophisticated things on up to this full
retrieval augmented generation model
which essentially marginalizes out the
evidence passage and gives us a really
powerful look at a good answer
conditional on that very complicated
prompt that we constructed
I think what you're seeing on the left
here is that we are going to move from
an era where we just type in prompts
into these models and hope for the best
into an era where prompt construction is
a kind of new programming mode where
you're writing down computer code could
be python code that is doing traditional
Computing things but also drawing on
very powerful pre-trained components to
assemble this kind of instruction kit
for your large language model to do
whatever task you have set for it and so
instead of Designing these AI systems
with all that fine tuning I described
before we might actually be moving back
into a mode that's like that symbolic
mode from the 80s where you type in a
computer program it's just that now the
program that you type in is connected to
these very powerful modern AI components
and we're seeing right now that that is
opening doors to all kinds of new
capabilities for these systems and this
first homework and Bake Off is going to
give you a glimpse of that and you're
going to use a programming model we've
developed called demonstrate search
predict that I hope will give you a
glimpse of just how powerful this can be
all right
we are out of time
right 420.
um so next time I'll show you a few more
units from the course and then we'll
dive into Transformers